[Music]
welcome to ear fest kids I'm link and
I'm Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting our Roy fab Ito
and Alex Buress creators of the popular
YouTube channel the wasabi Bros if you
don't already know the wasabi brothers
aren't actually brothers hate to burst
your bubble there they're best friends
we found a lot of parallels between the
Wasabi's that's what i'ma call the
Bobby's okay that makes it even more
like their brothers but okay yeah it's
not their last name you said their last
name I did that wasn't it it wasn't was
silence it was obvious Abhi's misspelled
so that's even more interesting and we
did talk about that but we there's a lot
of parallels between us and them and we
find a lot of those throughout
conversation like what it takes to be
best friends and business partners at
the same time and these guys are
successful business partners I mean the
wasabi bros YouTube channel wasabi
Productions has 3.4 million subscribers
they recently reached 1 billion video
views the channel really took off back
in 2012 and they created the characters
Rolanda and Richard for a parody of the
carly Rae Jepson music video call me
maybe you may have heard that song in
that video Roy who plays Rolanda is
wearing a skirt and a wig and has a huge
unibrow Alex plays himself and also a
character called Richard who's kind of
an awkward guy who also has a unibrow
this one drawn on with an obvious marker
yeah if this sounds like something that
would work on the internet you are right
it did and it has because it has
currently racked up 95 million views
here's a clip
[Music]
and I kiss you I wants your body you
you're so ugly gross and smelly can I
kiss you I watch your body why you know
like me
I so pretty can I kiss you
hi what's your body he'll your face is
crooked
[Music]
now Rolanda and Richard appeared in
several videos after this one and all of
them are hugely successful but beyond
Richard in Rolanda that wasabi bros make
other sketches also vlogs and challenge
videos they eat a lot of crazy stuff yes
like we also do on GMM all of their
videos have this sort of high school
friends or college roommates vibe to
them so you can go back to their
original videos from seven years ago and
you'll see a very similar feel to their
most recent videos and we discussed the
reasoning behind that we also talked
about their backstory meeting in Durham
North Carolina North Carolina another
parallel between us and them how they
started using Roy's dad's camera to make
videos that sounds familiar if you know
our story how did we didn't still Roy's
dad's camera yeah that's right we stole
my dad's camera but the thing that I'm
most excited about you guys hearing is
the conversation we had with them
towards the end of the podcast which was
more we got more counselor ish and more
therapeutic than we probably ever gotten
and I think it had to do with the fact
that we're two best friends who run a
business together and run a YouTube
channel together we know how difficult
it can be relationally yeah and so when
we find out that they've decided to move
into different places that alex is gonna
move out right and that it was Roy's
idea and they hadn't really talked about
it they actually talked about that for
the first time really on this air
biscuit yeah I mean we of course loved
it
we loved it when that kind of thing
happens on an air biscuit so yeah I mean
you tell us what you think as you listen
to that but we really did have a great
time yeah talking with the rossabi bros
and we know that you'll enjoy listening
to that but first we got to give a
little quick plug to our song biscuit
album y'all buy that on iTunes or Amazon
yes
and first of all if you haven't done it
yet
come on guys I mean sure the songs are
there on you on YouTube but you got to
carry the YouTube around with you all
the time you got to get them from the
iTunes of the Amazon so you can put them
you go in the subway tunnel and you lose
all internet and but you want to have a
song biscuit in your ear the only way
you can do that is by getting the song
at iTunes or Amazon so please do that
here's a clip from one of the songs the
bubbles bullet song featuring Lee Newton
[Music]
[Applause]
so thanks for heading over there and
downloading that if you so please and
now on with the biscuit
how many sound effects do you have I
have just the water drop loosely hit it
a few more times
Wow Roy's out in a beat good okay no I
just enjoy we were just watching
watching yeah
like one of you make a beat and then the
other one adds a sound and another sound
another sound it sounds cool we haven't
really done that
really maybe we should okay here's the
thing here's the thing this is why we're
not gonna do it really because they
won't know who's doing us you can't take
credit for it no I think and this is
something maybe we'll explore over the
of course it's conversation but rhett
and I are such good friends I know you
guys are great friends you go way back
to like middle school right mmm
and we'll talk about that but Ren are
such good friends since first grades we
got you always will that there's certain
things we're not comfortable doing that
like best friends do like well if you're
gonna do a sound effect I might add here
here's their now because it starts to
get a little embarrassed here's the
analogy know how good friends we are I
wouldn't do that with my wife and my
relationship with link is kind of like
my other marriage oh why is your wife
okay you know we are we're like old old
crotchety married couple and what an old
crotchety married couple start a beatbox
and then I mean you know the other ones
like just shut up you're embarrassing me
maybe because we've just known each
other for so long and we spent so much
time together which that we want to talk
about that too because just I I always
love it when there's so many parallels
with you guys but you know just from
where you're from and all that and I in
you know I think some of the insights
that we have into the way that we carry
out this whole business partnership I
love kind of seeing where somebody else
is and how so get ready to talk about
yourself let's start with this and
though do you ever get embarrassed by
your friendship it nests Mike
oh that's too bestfriend ashiness we got
a knot that you talked about it but I
don't think so no I just
just normal does yeah it's the same I
think we have a question well uh what
would you guys substitute for the
beatbox what would we do in yeah you
know I just said we would never do it if
we were to do it we do ya know like what
would be your substitute B I think it's
usually link saying what's that smell
and then I'm like oh it's not me and
then we just run around the room trying
to find the source of this man that is
our beatboxing and then he's like why
are you always so concerned about the
smell tracking down it's not it's it's
more just like a sound so I'll be like
like I'm ready to be this isn't about
this is about four of us right now all
right we'll do it right with the
bassline you'll come in with the optelec
thing again I know my role I'm getting
to the burial pictures and all these
guys do have us wouldn't do it but man
in middle school with its friends
forever
you two don't get millions of you why
did he turn into you you were supposed
to add a noisy you added the noise that
is your voice you guys want to be my
band yeah you just saw you just saw like
our week play out right here at the
table okay
the chalice talk about a challenge well
we were the challenge the challenge that
they did that we really like we want to
steal that idea from hmm the single bite
thing my challenge how'd you come up
with that we were uh we were actually at
dinner with a friend and he was like I
was eating and I was like I couldn't
finish I had a little bit left and he
was like yo one bite and I was a
what he's like I bet you can't eat that
in one bite and I was like huh one bite
and then we just thought I was like oh
we could put do like a whole lemon a
whole tomato we could do some other um
things like sausage and I saw the name
of it that's all the video title I was
like okay well this is gonna be like you
just put a bunch of nasty stuff one bite
or whatever but then when I saw that it
was no I'm gonna pull this corn dog and
try to eat a corn dog one bite that was
great I gotta say I was actually a
little bit like when you got the pickle
yeah in your mouth I was like he is
going to die I had to help me I came on
YouTube here was like a cartoon yeah the
way it was I could not get a it was the
worst part is like when you bit into the
tomato or the pickle or whatever it was
it would squirt out because it's just so
much your mouth it's got nowhere to go
yeah well but the thing that we do have
in common the challenge that we you guys
took kind of took it a different way you
tried the Carolina Reaper well there's
people you went straight for the Seas
tell us about that it was hot
well why did you why did you go with
seeds and now it's because I ordered it
on Amazon and that was the actual pepper
I was like okay and then I came in and
they were just well you know the only
reason we got ahold of one is because we
did the original ghost pepper challenge
and then a lot of people were saying you
guys should do the Carolina Reaper and
then a guy in North Carolina mm-hmm I'm
familiar shipped it to us shipped us
three three of them they smell like
death yeah I mean you only had the seed
did the seed smell no no I thought it
was like maybe the season won't be as
hot but they're they're still pretty hot
they weren't as hot as I assumed the
pepper is but did you see the last yeah
posted something today oh okay okay I
want to talk about this okay because I
saw your vlog amount to nine million
Scoville yen sauce of death or whatever
so you push that video out today yeah we
have it okay so I have actually kind of
already drawn the line we first what
link says he's
doing any more peppers that are hotter
than the Carolina Reaper like when they
come out with that and I'm basically
saying okay I'll do it even though I'm
not looking forward to it but I'm
drawing a lot I'm not doing any of that
extract yeah three times hotter than the
Carolina Reaper well we did dropper no
we had we had we're supposed to get
toothpicks so we didn't have to the big
so we got this dry spaghetti noodle and
touch it to it and put in our mouth and
we both died it was instant pain tearful
I mean I was like waterfall his like
snot was running out it was gross so
like a drop base no not even a nice not
a drop yeah it was just a touch to the
sauce and it's a solid sauce it's like
it's like a candle wax consistency
mm-hmm really yeah good so what was the
reaction Oh like I was he was trying to
talk and I was I couldn't talk at all
cuz had it worse because you had the
spaghetti noodle yeah and then he
actually ate the whole spaghetti noodles
so the actual extract got on his throat
yeah the throat is the worst everybody
the throat it's okay when I did it both
the ghost pepper every stage is there
everything is going through but the
babies are many stages the final stage
was horrible for link because he didn't
eat bananas yeah that's the secret Oh
Nana's before and after I like ate
banana whereas I do is that I don't know
does it help the heater helps like that
like absorbs the stuff in your stomach
and counteracts it anymore we already
did the nine million there's nothing
harder than that right
there will be there will be so that was
the hottest sauce in the world I mean I
see ya doing that you guys can take that
crown let me ask this are you guys
instinctively this adventurous as just
people or is it your you're willing to
do things that then you want to you want
to produce great episodes and great
content that's gonna that's gonna
perform well so would you have done that
without cameras rolling no no I mean I
would have liked like I would not that I
would have maybe tried a pepper if my
friends wanted to do it but I wouldn't
be like in my room alone bag I'll eat
this pepper right now and just feed it I
would at least tweet it I think about
the past few years of our lives
the you just we don't have crazy things
that we've done intentionally that
haven't been part of a video because
you're like whoa if I'm gonna tell that
story or I'm gonna do that that's gonna
be four views mm-hmm
you guys are kind of living that same
thing they probably even more than we
are because we do the Willett or the
weird food or the hot pepper but it's
it's less regular than you guys are
doing it yeah we just I don't know they
just really like that stuff so we do it
and then our favorite thing to do is
sketches but they like that so we're
like okay we'll torture ourselves a
little bit right he is better at it
because I always do it after him even
though we're like same time it's like I
can't I don't know why I just stop but
there's one thing that we will never do
and it's because of him okay oh yeah yes
yeah something's really scared of but is
it is it okay so it's animal-related
oh you know what no is it related no I
think it's not more something that
you're scared of this is give you an
idea the kind of research that we do for
your business
oh you're scared of being shocked we
have a cane we have a shot cane as a
stun gun we have both been shocked by it
so hold on so you're afraid to be I'm
not shocked I'm not for anything is that
because because you have been shocked
yeah when I was like five I was a I
don't know my uncle had like this gadget
or this little generator battery
generator and I was just I just touched
it and I chucked me for like straight
like three seconds like seized up it
like grabbed hold of you yeah you
couldn't get away from you was glued to
it yeah so how does the fear of being
shocked impact you beyond not making a
video about being shocked I mean like
there's not a lot of shock risk from day
to day right like you don't plug things
in I do I do I mean the actual just
physical touch of electricity Hey but
when you're plugging things in do you
like you're very conscious of it I'm not
God my hand on the inside of the prong
it's not a neurosis No
that's good it's just I'm not gonna make
that video yeah yeah I'm glad to get him
to do it on my car man is he cool cuz
you're so scared of it it'll reaction
will be awesome and he's like no I'm
serious like never you know this one
time in seventh grade uh one of my
classmates he had like one of those
electric shock he pins and is like hey
can I borrow a pencil or a pen I was
like okay and I actually touched it I
screamed so loud what's wrong I was like
I got jacked I put I seen you in the
outlet one time well my brother did it
first and then he said it hurt so I
wanted to I don't want the check and it
hurt it did hurt did you unlock
something no nothing yes I've been
shocked by just like the wall outlet
before it's not pleasant now back in
when you were five getting shot that was
in the Philippines you live in
Philippines I don't know I I was there I
grew up there for like two years when I
was like five or six five and six yeah
so you where were you before uh here you
were here then you moved there no I was
born there then I moved here when I
student went back day one is five came
back here on a six or seven and then
that Olivia okay so your parents
Filipino yeah and where are you from
Alex I'm uh I'm a half-filled you know
you're half Filipino mm-hmm but you
never live there no I just went there
for the first time this year yeah this
year for a friend's wedding okay and it
was on my top place to go so so where
did you grow up I was born in Montana
Montana and like when I was like one we
moved to the Kentucky and then when I
was ten we moved to North Carolina and
then when I was 24 I moved here okay
Ellie yeah and so that yeah we got the
North Carolina connection so when you
were 10 you moved in North Carolina
where you already were yeah you see and
that was when you guys met we met like
when I was like 13 I think we met a
middle school boy he doesn't remember I
think I thought I was high school until
he told me it was middle school and I
was like and but you live close to each
other right yeah the same street and you
lived there for a few years without
really knowing each other no no we knew
each other because our family filipinos
just are drawn together was it like a
Filipino community yeah yeah
but there was a lot of Filipino families
in our neighborhood and this is in
Durham North Carolina yeah yeah good so
not far from where we grew up
mmm where was you Buies Creek so like 40
miles south of Raleigh so I'm not far
you know we might have been in our
corner trap from Durham okay maybe an
hour yeah and you all three want to NC
State right yeah yeah yes three who's
the third one you think oh yes so let's
talk about this so you guys meet middle
school high school whatever one middle
school yeah and and what was that is
there an epic first meeting story
apparently not since you don't remember
I was a wedding in middle school and
waiting for my parents to get me and
this guy comes out of nowhere with the
cards like like that was our first
encounter he doesn't remember that good
that was a spot on Alex yeah and it's
still high now but it was really high I
wasn't gonna say there my nickname was
Mickey Mouse in middle school and it was
bad what was a magic trick
I don't remember I don't know I was
probably just trying to impress a girl
or something and I was like hey I'm
gonna go get that Filipino guy to do
this trick sawed in half or something no
I know those cards and you made one
disappear I don't know was it cool I was
like okay so what was what was Durham
North Carolina growing up what was that
like for you guys I don't know I just
kind of just got used to it
super chill a lot of cheese tobacco you
got tobacco warehouses yeah there's like
downtown Jeremy did that we went to the
woods a lot cuz we would in our
neighborhood there's like this trail
that led to the woods and we would build
a fort Durham is cut has kind of a
dichotomy that you've got like the nice
Durham and then you've got like the
dangerous Durham like the
I'm Durham yeah so where did you fall on
that you got the Duke University Durham
and then you got the like drive by
Durham oh really Kim yeah that's like
mixed some places we went to you're like
ten minutes away from the hospital I
went to northern high school high school
and it was like it was the school that
is like oh there's like I remember we
were Riverside which is the better new
school and then we moved a little bit
farther so he went to northern and when
I went to Northern there was I think
there was like 27 fights in the first
month dude it was like borderline ghetto
boy I liked rednecks and yeah so after
all of them got expelled then there's no
more fights cuz all the fighters got
expelled but then there was a bomb
threat called one time and they made all
the students go into the field into the
football field and then it turned and
then everybody apparent there's just all
these fights every was bringing out a
fight so we're like what's going on and
a gang called the school called a bomb
threat to get everybody outside so they
can fight like like take them out like
fight them and then people are like heat
strokes cops are trying to get people
everybody's trying to Jew come and then
other kids are like running for the cars
and the teachers like don't go anywhere
even though there's fights everywhere
and I was protecting my girlfriend at
the time and I was like getting punched
in the back by random people it was
crazy free-for-all yeah so we're really
we're pretty pretty gangster sounds like
it what what was the dynamic in being
Filipino and how did that play out was
that a thing or was it like that's not a
thing you know I mean was because we're
from North Carolina yeah we know how
right you know there is a tendency to
point out everyone's differences very
early on oh no I don't know I just I
just look daft it yeah I didn't really
think about that stuff like I mean
everyone says every now and then they'd
be like hey yeah our family Asian hey
yeah so it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't a
thing it wasn't you wouldn't call it a
struggle no there's probably like I was
probably one of their like probably one
two three Asians in all my class so I
was usually the Asian guy in the class
and that's it
like it wasn't it wasn't nobody ever
said hey
and where you either of you both of you
can speak to this were you kind of
becoming the class clown the entertainer
oh yeah I did I was in detention all the
time I was getting in trouble all the
time but the teachers I was like really
good friends of the teachers like all
the teachers got along like I wasn't
very good in grades but I never failed
because the teachers like oh it's just
Alex we'll let him pass okay thank you I
was more like the just calm guy
following the rules and stuff like you
were studious yes so then when did
things start to develop you know what
was percolating that led to being
youtubers how did that start
oh okay an eighth grade parents got a
camera they would never use so I took it
and I just made some random like back in
the day is like lipstick videos videos
this was pre YouTube yeah like the first
day I ever yeah so you made lip sync
videos and for who just not for the
internet mm-hmm no no I just was bored
it's like yo I have a camera and then I
windows movie maker maybe I can make
something out of it and that was my
mindset
I made some random videos and then
YouTube was there it was just a platform
for like videos at the day and then we
saw a storage space okay instead of like
we didn't like so he could show his
family and friends if he puts it on
there but oh you can just go here and
watch it and that's why the YouTube
channel is actually called oh yeah Troy
yeah because it was just your idea
you're I'm starting this yeah yeah you
guys weren't collaborating on that at
the time what was the what what what
were you doing after that you were his
lip sync videos just you know there's
like eight I just got a whole bunch of
my friends like y'all you wanna make a
video with me there alright and then
later on he came I like I don't know
like he got into it and then he like saw
it was like a hobby a passion of his
because he's like teaches himself
everything so he taught himself guitar
piano drums editing and all this stuff
and then everybody else kind of like
fell off and like they just like their
kids they got bored
whatever and then he's like hey Alex
could make a video and I live down the
street ok so Alex was like the second
string yeah it was a hobby production
was it called wasabi productions no just
for its right at the time
ok wasabi came when I watched jackass
the movie when steve-o snorted wasabi
and I have never heard the word wasabi
before I was like oh that's a cool word
and then I misspelled it
oh so it's so it's not a play on ass
it's just wasabi misspelled where wasabi
with extra ass so it works yeah so you
brought Alex in on what you were doing
whenever all your other true friends
abandoned yeah we can do it I was
recruiting so then you cuz how are you
guys know 23:25 ok so you kind of
experienced high school and YouTube
success all at the same time yeah it was
weird because we went to different high
schools but we lived near each other and
then I moved to next to him but for one
more year we stayed at the high school I
was at and then I moved to his and when
I went to his we were already making
videos for like a year and everybody at
the high school knew me and it was weird
for me and I was like whoa yeah that was
you know I think you guys might be the
first people that we've talked to that
experienced that success while in high
school that's a what does that like
everybody smile Smosh - its kind of the
same thing and at the same time yeah
yeah that's true yeah so and what people
liked the videos it wasn't like oh you
guys are weird for doing that like oh no
it's like I only wanted to be a part of
it
and what do you think I mean at that
time did you have some kind of sense
that like yeah this is pretty cool this
might go somewhere did you guys have a
did either of you have more of a
business mindset towards like this could
become something or is it just like this
is cool I don't know what I'm gonna do
it is
aha be like okay let's keep making
videos or whatever because we didn't
make any like money oh yeah at the
beginning it wasn't for money we didn't
knew but you did but it was called
wasabi productions I mean it sounded
like a put it on the front of the videos
even yeah so there was a little bit of
that mindset that like I were um you
lating anyone else it was it just we
want to seem legitimate or it would just
be fun to call ourselves something
productions yeah their productions or
Phil oh my god yeah so it was
aspirational yeah yeah but you gave it
up to go to college you kind of had to
get real yeah for like so what what was
once we stopped what was that decision
point like when you were graduated from
high school you're big on YouTube right
yeah but we still didn't like it wasn't
like a big revenue source or like
anything we're just making videos for
fun and then we were like oh time to
grow up and then eventually we were like
man we missed it so we just came back
and then then it blew up again and we're
like whoa so you went to you went to NC
State um to to study what computer
engineering pewter engineering our alma
mater and what where did you go what did
you do I went to the University of
YouTube no I was like I said I was a
class clown so I wasn't very good in
school and I went to Community College
for a couple years but it wasn't for me
even in Community College I was still
the class clown I didn't want to be just
it's just part of me just making people
have so you kind of had to wait for Roy
to come back around to this the YouTube
idea is that is that well I mean we just
both stopped I went to work I was like
working two jobs and then he was in
school and then we just like really hey
let's just make videos again just for
fun whenever we have time like on in the
summer or something we're still in
whatever video yeah and I would drive
from Durham to Raleigh
oh I remember one time uh I don't know
what caused me to think like you know
let's make videos again but I had like a
I pod touch at the time I was like
I should sell this for a just like a
decently nice camera so I sold it and
used the money to buy a decent nice
camera along with like the money I got
from work and that's when we started
back up again okay so you see got the
camera and then what did you what did
you make was it a decision to just start
it back up more lip sync videos or
sketches or was it and was did something
really blow up then or was it just more
of oh we're it just pick up right where
you left off at first we just did
sketches for a bit and then we heard
about the old like partnership program
so we deleted all the videos and just
just posted every like once probably
like once a month yeah and then we got
more serious yeah then he would all he
would drive all the way to rally from
Dara I'm like every like week and then
we would still miss random stuff yeah
and then it was until the whole Rolanda
thing yeah kind of just blew us up a
little bit yeah they loved this
character yeah and so how did those
characters come about the Rolanda and
Richard before the call me maybe video
yeah yeah he came to me with a script I
was like hey or I was like we're in
Florida and I think and when the call me
maybe song came out and I was like dude
listen to his song it's just crazy and
then like a week later he's like hey by
the way I wrote a parody for that song I
like okay and then then we started
making the parody and then then we're
like oh he had these two we had these
characters and we're like okay and then
we brought them to life like he became
Rolanda and I became Richard and we
decided like to draw on her faces and
make it like really out there yeah
Rolanda Rolanda was born because back in
middle school I used to I guess be girl
for like Halloween one of those like
middle school Halloween parties so would
you show up with like a yes you did yeah
I guess so whenever they would have
skirt and like my chest area in a
unibrow
not not a unibrow okay I don't know how
the unibrow came alive we just we knew
some nice brush we knew she was like
Alex was like the heartthrob and we
needed somebody gross and disgust and
that's where came from and then we
needed somebody even worse to be rolando
stalkers okay Richard him No
that was that worked yeah so when you
put did the Rolanda voice happen after
you saw yourself in the mirror oh I have
no idea might give us the give us the
voice like that that just how much
developed more into that I don't know I
think yeah right for the mirror like yo
ever asks you like hey how should this
character sound so I just tried to fit
voices it's like gross oh yeah he did
yeah I remember you're like hey how's
this and then how about this huh and
then say with Richard actually something
happens he's got a weird voice - yeah he
does we were going we must give us a
little richer because we were in the
middle of filming and then he had to go
home for something he's like oh I run
home and there's like five miles away
and then when he came back I took a nap
and when he woke up everybody let's go
and I was really tired and I was like
okay things I just do some crazy boy
sounds like I was just really tired like
super demo and then it just and then
tired that you couldn't talk to your man
and then I just sounded cool and then
eventually like you can really
understand what he was saying so I had
to clear it up a little bit but it was
really a leg you couldn't even
understand at the beginning and that
video almost has 100 million views now
it does like all these years later like
people just go back and comment and it's
like I watched this when I was a kid
yeah it's still hilarious now that's
what the comments are and I'm sure
there's still kids yeah you know in in
one sense but the thing that you know
for that video to blow up so huge my
assumption was oh that was just out of
nowhere but what I didn't realize was
that I mean now when I look back the
preceding videos on your channel
we're still getting millions of views
yeah but that one and those up but yeah
but yeah so yeah so the ones the earlier
ones blew up because I mean they were
big but they were so big
yeah so when that happened you're in
you're in school mm-hmm and you're kind
of like let's make this a thing like
what was that conversation like and you
didn't what happened was cool unit of
finishing right oh yeah I changed my
major let's change it to one thing uh
film studies oh you didn't drop out you
just film studies yeah his parents
actually said they're like hey we know
that your business is like kind of blew
me right now and if you want to move to
LA which we feel is the right thing then
we won't be mad at you for not finishing
he's like no I'm gonna finish for you
but what did you have to say about that
I was like I'll wait I'm not gonna leave
them alone my mom actually said finish
school
oh really yeah yeah I thought you told
me that they said it's fine if you
wanted to no that's your parents get
confused you start to take his story but
what so for the record your mom was like
you gotta get a degree okay you can wear
that unibrow and get you know tens of
millions of views and probably shout out
some Carly Rae Jepsen did she shout you
out I don't know I want to meet you
wanna meet you call me maybe she's
listening right now but she said you got
to get that degree did you get the
degree I did I did yeah yeah I did it
because her dream was to you know for
all her kids to get a degree so it meant
something for you guys to go to college
and finish it you're like I'm gonna make
that happen
but you're in the midst of this success
and by that point with a partner program
I'm assuming some financial success so
you're like okay this we could do this
we can afford to move to LA and by this
point because I'm gonna kind of track
the evolution of it kind of being this
hoitz Roy thing to being wasabi
productions like when did this become a
thing where it was like
this is a business partnership this is
this this is our friendship but it's
also a business partnership and this is
gonna be our thing like did you were you
guys thinking that in college oh yeah
actually probably like a month after the
whole Carly or either call me maybe
video boom and then we saw like the I
guess our paycheck or like whoa yeah and
it just became like the same every
single month and then that's when we
like talked to each other like yo we
gotta do something about this so yeah it
freaked us out because the first time we
actually got a big like paycheck from
what we're doing we've already been
doing it for like years and then we went
to Florida to see some friends and I'll
probably make it like $2,000 a month
and then we I was like we went there and
then I was like on the way back we
stopped to eat and I was like me and I
was stressing out and I was like man I
should not have spent that much money
what am I gonna do like I got a I don't
know I was just stressing out and he's
like ah let me let me check it was sabe
and see maybe there's something and then
he was like whoa and then he showed me I
was like I was like come on man stop
playing like I'm really stressed out
he's like no this is real this is a fake
and I was like what and we just like I
don't know we just started pacing the
Zaxby's we were in in Georgia so what
was that conversation like what was the
conversation was like we got to get
serious was it like a week that we
didn't know if it was like a started
happening we thought it was like a
one-time thing and the next month is the
same thing and the next month it was
even more and we're like whoa and then
then we got a financial financial
advisor yeah he actually suggested that
we should just like sorry business and
then we just went from there yeah and
then we got now we got like retirement
funds and so we're in like stocks and
all like investing and everything but
cuz it wasn't just that one video you
kept making videos I mean the very next
video
you brought back those two characters
that's got 20 million views then Richard
was back in the next video I mean it was
like yeah
every few weeks you kind of once at work
you laid
to it right you and that one just got
thank you almost 40 million which is
really smart you know a lot of I mean
because you weren't new to the game you
were totally ready to capitalize on it
and you saw it seems like you started to
break out music in real life - mm-hmm
you know that and then people were going
back getting older videos and we
actually a music my life we didn't know
any other youtubers or anything but we
saw Steve's thing like we're good
friends with Steve Barney yeah Steve
Cardinal and we uh we saw him we're like
oh that's a cool idea but you know like
how people do print um challenges now
and then everybody does challenge you
didn't sound like that we're like wow
he's really funny let's make a video
like him we didn't think of it as like
oh we're taking is this thing yeah and
then I didn't realize that until like
we've already made like three and then
he he actually tweeted at me and he was
a little upset and I was like I was like
oh I'm dude I'm sorry
happy yeah I thought you would like it
and then we didn't know was gonna blow
up like it did so I could see how he
could be upset about it but really we
were so sorry we're he's like oh we're
not gonna make any more okay and then
he's like okay but now your friends yeah
and then I saw him in person and as soon
as I saw him he's like dude I'm so sorry
I was having a bad day that day like I
don't I just needed somebody to like
talk like get mad at and he's happened
to be there and I was like okay and now
he's really cool now the interesting
thing is that your videos still have a
certain vibe to them it's kind of a it's
they still have the hey my parents found
a guy got my parents camera and we're
having fun hanging a video right yeah
well how would you describe it odd happy
yeah I would describe it as we were kids
when we started and we never left that
kind of theme so we even though we got
older we kept the same like so right so
is that it that might as my question is
was that calculated to be like yeah but
this is all right please stuck with it
and we got we learned how to like master
that vibe so like kids love it and we
know how to make kids laugh and our
fanbase is like 3 to like 18 year olds
and there's a lot of times parents come
up to us because the kids are too young
and they're scared to say hi and the
parents recognize this or the kids are
like
and so so how has so this is kind of two
two-part question is who do you picture
like when you think of a fan who do you
picture like you guys have somebody in
mind when you're making a video and then
how's the fact that your fans are our
younger how's that impacted like the
content and how far you go and we stay
mostly PG and family-friendly because of
our families and because like brand
friendly I would think of like someone
like Shay Carlos kids yeah yeah yeah
they're a really big fan so yeah fans I
always imagine them yeah as long as we
cater our like content towards them then
yeah something that like we wouldn't
want parents to not let their kids watch
em hmm
right so you keep that in mind yeah and
has that been I mean you know we do a
similar thing I think that we move the
stuff that we create we think of okay
we'd like a family to be able to sit
down and enjoy this we may not have a
kid in mind when we develop it but you
know we'd like a family to to to be able
to enjoy it I mean has that been a
frustration for you not really I don't
think so mm-hmm
cuz I don't know we're not really late
there's not a lot of youtubers like us
like family-friendly and actually aim
for the younger we're like the disney
channel of youtube i have a lot of
friends they do pranks who are they like
cuss or they do vlogs and like other
people are saying things that we
wouldn't usually say and i guess over
time you can get used to just the
content you produce yeah and that's what
we we do like a lot of slapstick we slap
each other like yeah hurt each other
literally slap each other yeah yeah he
punched me in the stomach one time oh
dude there's like this one take I
remember you couldn't get the stop right
so you can slap it really like good
that's right okay I've looked in one
time I think he like sprained his ankle
remember that one where I tried to get
you over my back or like this and then
you like did it like 10 times and then
at one you're like oh no no no say wait
I can't I can't my like stuff like that
cuz it doesn't I mean it's just pain
it's fine it's just pain pain is that
one that will change it's very it's just
a pain that will not
go away is what will start to happen
trust me you guys live together - yeah
okay so like the couches that you guys
are perched on when you're doing
different challenges or like in the in
the patio area this is like where you
actually live where you shoot yeah you
shoot where you live you know yeah it's
not like your videos I don't know why
well the way you said it sounded like
you live where you shoot or like you
were expecting somebody to finish
thinking about this I was like I'm
unintentionally making it sound like
that don't crap where you eat thing
don't crap where you eat or eat when you
finish good enough myself shoot where
you crap
so I mentioned it a couple of things
first of all just the creative approach
for you guys and in the intersection
between your friendship and your your
lives and being business partners the
thing that I think read alluded to
earlier so first let's just explore the
the creative approach you have you have
a schedule it's like every Wednesday you
got to come out with a video and you're
very consistent with that which is
pretty key you know everyone who's
successful says that I'm sure you guys
get say that too how challenging is it
to to keep it going you know when you've
got that Weekly thing are you in a
what's the creative process well since
we moved to LA we have a team now like
we used to do all our stuff all around
now we have two guys that helped us out
with everything the lighting camera
editing so that do they live with you -
no because I get that vibe it's like
okay now they're perched on the back of
the couch in this video I don't know man
could you put them in the videos - yeah
Kyle and will will yeah okay and there
are there youtubers and we met them when
we came out here because we were looking
for people to help us out and then um it
turns a hot like when we started hanging
out of them a lot and we became really
good friends now as a team in terms of
the
how do you guys divide up the creative
process is there like a division of
labor here I used to do a lot of editing
but now that we have a team editing now
we both write mm-hmm and what those
scripts back and forth and now we have
we actually have them see what they
think about it usually we film in bulk
so we come like are like mmm seven
videos in two weeks and then yeah just
release it but and after that we take
like a month off to just like think of
ideas and write because we need that
time to think yeah okay sometimes we get
like you know writer's block or whatever
yeah and it's really just it's like well
there's an interesting dynamic too
because I know Roy you have a daily vlog
you're doing basically a daily video
yeah I decided and you've got snapchat
and Alex you don't kind of have that
you've got your Twitter and that kind of
thing chat a lot your case you're doing
snapchat - yeah but the daily see like
are you doing the daily vlog and editing
that - are you getting some of the team
to edit that no I so like how is like
the way that we work together there's
this like if one of us when one of us
wouldn't decide to do a daily vlog
because we would have a conversation
about it before we did it would be like
you can't do that because you won't be
able to do this you know what I'm saying
like how that how does that work with
you guys it's like no I'm gonna do this
and it's not gonna get in the way is
that a cut you guys have a conversation
before you decide to do something like
that how does that work he just started
but I'm not upset about anything used to
be a gaming channel oh yeah oh crap yeah
I have no time for game so I'm just
gonna change it to vlogging channel but
is that something indicative about your
personality that you're kind of like a
starter like I'm gonna go I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna start the channel I'm
gonna start the daily vlog yeah I just
like to be predicative yeah he's
definitely a self start like everything
he likes to learn on his own like just
like all the instruments like everything
is self-taught with him and then I like
having like direction like I only
haven't been taught he likes learning by
himself I guess also just the fact that
we're here in LA now just get the
I just you know just to do something so
right ideas so again so alex is there a
motivation issue here with you know do
it actually my brother is moving out
here in September we're moving into
separate places and my brother's moving
out to move in with me and we're gonna
start like a brother vlog so we'll be
like a little twist to like just Alex
and now the other brother so could your
brother already YouTube's YouTube
channel and so we're gonna do it
together to be cool so yeah so how does
that work you know you're you guys have
different side projects that you're
working on and it still is it is it
totally side project or is it still
something with them with sabi
productions how you guys worked out
means more like a hobby this is
something to do every single day but I
get the impression that if if you go off
and do something like that and you're
like he didn't he didn't really talk
about it he just kind of did it mhm
it's it do you got like how often you
guys have like alright let's talk about
wasabi production so let's talk about
where we're at where we're going or is
it kind of just like this is kind of
you're kind of going you're kind of
making up as you go along and like this
work it's okay that he started out
because he did spend a lot of time
editing because I never edited I did
mostly writing and then um he did all
editing and then now that we have a team
doing it editing he had so much free
time that we both have a lot free time
so I travel a lot and then he does the
vlogs and um that's just what we started
doing with our time extra time and now
I'm gonna start doing the daily vlogs
and travel what yeah okay and travel so
what's behind the separation you guys
are separated now he's gonna be
something coming out yeah what's behind
that I don't know why are we separating
[Laughter]
the first time I heard about it is he
came to me I was like hey I think we
should we just moved it or we moved we
live together in Raleigh once we started
getting bigger I was like
makes sense like we'll fill them
together at the same place and then we
moved here and a couple months after we
moved in he was like hey I think we
should separate when the lease is up and
I was like why and he said our
lifestyles are different and I was like
okay and then I don't know why I've
never asked for explanation I just
agreed so well let's talk about it now
yes explanation yeah yeah what's
different about your lifestyles right
I'm asking Roy I asked you today all
right our lifestyles are different
because controversy yeah Roy your idea
you know you do today uh-oh there's a
just there's a diplomatic well I don't
know there's a diplomatic way to
approach it or maybe not
you basically said her life cells are
different uh he does things I don't do
I do things easy synergize yeah so how
does that how does that impact you guys
your creative collaboration are you
saying that this is also a creative
separation no all right well he said
what he said that we are live different
but he wants to grow as an individual
and that makes sense because we've been
together for so long and we've always
been like right next door or like a
short drive away and um so separating
would I think I I could see how it could
be good I mean I I don't I don't I like
living with you but I mean it doesn't
matter like I know we don't like butt
heads it's just we I do do some stuff
that he doesn't okay but from a creator
not gonna miss but currently one of them
can be heard
well fatally I think it's a good thing
another house to film in there we go is
right well that's that's a kind of yeah
the is it I think this would be better
ultimately for wasabi productions if we
did not live together isn't is that part
of it I don't know I feel like we'll
still see each other yeah like venture
territory we've never been separate so
we're gonna see it's like yeah but Roy
this being your ID okay good was I think
what Red's asking is was it a was it a
personal decision or a business decision
and it sounds like it was just a
personal decision oh yeah it was a
personal and then from a from a business
standpoint or a youtube channel or a
Content standpoint that that didn't play
into the decision you just assume that
the plan is for publicly in terms of
your content nothing's gonna change
yeah I don't think it's gonna offend how
we work together at all cuz we're still
gonna be like close to each other like
we already talked about we're gonna be
either in the same community or like
really close so we don't have to drive
far to work yeah yeah so and you're
gonna keep the schedule intact oh yeah
yeah yeah because I mean you guys know
is it one of the things that we've
experienced over the years is that one
of the reasons that we've been so
consistent with content at least would
like GMM being able to do that for a few
years it's the two of us I mean it's
like it'd be so difficult to do this by
yourself no yeah well daily vlogs like
or like kind of a one-person thing I
think whatever you're saying but I'm
saying like you know what snobbery
Productions continuing and continuing to
evolve and you guys growing and growing
that it's kind of the thing that in
order for it to be successful you kind
of gotta break the other you got to do
it you guys yeah we're ever gonna
separate no it's never gonna be like hey
I'm leaving and you're on your own we're
always gonna be together it's just very
moving into our houses yeah yeah yeah
growing up yes probably growing up to
see what it's like okay
and now are we okay guys anything else
you want to talk about to each other
talk to each other yeah
alright I'll put it to you this way you
know will will will gladly be a resource
for comedic duo youtuber advice if you
have any questions for us related to
that we'd love to be of assistance to
patch things up because clearly just
kidding yeah well you know here's the
thing I will say is that we we talked to
Smosh hmm ask them similar questions and
I think we got it was interesting I
think we got a pretty similar response
and I think it might just be the fact
that we're almost 40 years old mm-hmm
and like we've you know like we we were
married with kids separate families
before this whole YouTube thing started
and it was so it had to work as a
business and there was so much like in
we're super analytical and there's just
these constant conversations that go
back and forth when we kind of we were
talking to Ian and Anthony about things
it's kinda like they were well we aren't
really like they ended up having this I
guess where they were talking to each
other in a way that you could tell they
never talked to each other yeah you know
that's a plug for going back and
listening to but I kind of see the same
thing happening yeah but with you guys
is he right was it Roy had this idea
that you guys should live separately and
you were just like well ok yeah you
really surprised oh I thought I did
something wrong but I didn't like we're
not really like we don't really talk
like straight forward like hey stop
doing that or I don't know so what kind
of passive aggressive each other so he
was like hey we do this and I was like I
didn't ask like why or did I do
something I was just like okay and so
that's it but we're working on that
we're trying that we had a talk how
would you get you have a talk yeah I
talked to you last week yeah like hey
man I got serious I mean most of the
time the serious talks with us happen in
the in the midst of like a argument
it isn't like hey let's have a
discussion it's never had arguments
I'm mad at you right now and then it
turns into let's talk about our
relations is really why I'm mad and then
it becomes a like a relationship
check-in yeah we would we could we would
not still be working together without
those check-ins so nice
it's not what you're saying Roy he said
no I actually didn't see who said it
just then when you said we've actually
never had a fight yeah that's me I don't
think we've ever had like a
straightforward argument where he was
like I'm mad at you and I was like I'm
mad at you I think do you think that's a
problem well I don't really ever get mad
no because I think we rent I are our
stances that's a sign of a problem yeah
so we should get mad more often yeah I
mean yes just well you should vocalize
and what you're actually feeling when
you are mad because you're human and
when you work this close to somebody
there's got to be some conflict I mean
if you're it's a lot like a marriage I
mean we were kind of joking but when you
when you work together as closely as we
do as you guys have to to be as
successful as you're and then when you
become as successful as you are mmm
there's it's a it's a complicated
relationship where I mean there's money
involved there's there's friendship
involved there's and name all other
things there's kids involved yeah
together you can't do anything
ultimately that doesn't affect the
partnership and some to some degree oh
man my heart I feel so warm I was like I
was like because sometimes I feel like
you were mad at me and I didn't know why
and then but we don't talk so I was just
like peeing it so I would try to figure
it out on my own and then like it would
never like fixed it I mean I don't I
don't know what it is oh I just like
always felt like you were annoyed by me
for like a while and I was like I was
like oh maybe it's a phase but it was
for a while and then you talked about it
then you wrote this so you just can't it
into the sketch it called annoying so
annoying so Roy you wrote so annoying
the sketch and is that a
passive-aggressive way to address no I
was not actually
I'm not YouTube there it was actually
like a sketch like a renewal sketch for
our old videos that we deleted okay okay
good good okay all right we're not gonna
make you guys can just talked about your
relationship later you're on time you
don't do it let's call you feel proud
yeah I'll call you for round two and
podcast
one interesting Dynamis into this back
and the answers are all there okay yeah
that's true
yeah are you guys seeing things that
you're not saying that you're like we
are we have seen everything where you
guys there when we talked like we bugged
you for the past three years yeah
now there's another interesting dynamic
and that is the ladies mm-hmm Alex
you're you've kind of struck a chord
with the ladies I mean how you know
anytime you take your shirt off in a
video it's like there's a social media
well that's for buzz so that will happen
and that's my question is does that
become something that it's like all
right there's gonna be there's gonna be
a topless moment and this know usually
in it I'm like hey I can take my shirt
off for that cool and then I do I just
it's not because I'm like cocky I might
look at my body it's because it makes
it's like further videos like so what is
calculated though yeah to add a little
sex appeal little bit not like Royer you
like writing it into sketches that all
started actually because of the call me
maybe I became like the heartthrob
because he wrote me as a heartthrob and
then from there I just became like
typecast as the heart through just
playing a role now yeah now I'm just
like in that role forever
because I mean Roland oh that's it like
Rolanda Alex so Alex has to be the
heartthrob that rule Anna wants and then
it just makes Khan it makes for landed
that much grosser mmm you know what
maybe there is some truth maybe maybe
something about the love triangle that
you guys have created between the two of
you on you two
maybe that could be therapeutic somehow
just talk through that if you can work
through the love triangle of Richard
Rolanda
in Aleks huh you could solve all kinds
of problems
talk about our feelings as Richard and
Roland hey listen that might be the key
is my puppet talk to your puppet yeah
that's not a bad idea at all no you're
not mad at me right now I've never felt
like you were mad at me
and you wouldn't you wouldn't tell me
you just like it's good I don't know I
just felt like you're mad at me bro I
like a lot of times and I would never
know what it is and then I would get an
idea of it so like the one thing you're
like that we're not gonna talk about
that I that you know I tried to contain
it and then the other like stuff I try
to contain I try to contain everything
that I think bothers you that you
wouldn't that you don't tell me about
you well you just do up to me be like
hey are you mad at me I could what would
you tell him but would you be straight
up with him yeah okay all right let me
think about this for a second and then I
met you cuz yeah yeah but I'm scared
like you're not mad and then you're like
not even married
what am i I don't know what I'm scared
about I don't know I just
we got a a well yeah we have some stuff
we got work yeah it is actually after
that talk like last week I feel like our
relationship has gotten better just in
this last week but we never like you
guys making us seem like we hate each
other okay no no but listen man I think
it's normal it's totally normal when you
when you work out yeah yeah you know
every duo we've talked to and we talked
to corridor digital they had this whole
thing where they had to develop a signal
on set for when they got into an
argument so that that person it was a
flash it's a flash but they call it
flash card they play the card wild card
wild card yeah when you play the wild
card which is just like saying wild card
yeah you get your way and you get one of
those per day so that they wouldn't buy
heads they would fight on shoots in
front of Oh
Barriss himself I think everybody I mean
this applies to people who are in
relationships in general but and we kind
of got over the self-consciousness a
long time ago of talking about our
friendship and our creative partnership
as if it was a relationship because I
mean let's face it that's what it is
it's not a romantic relationship but it
is a relationship and so when you spend
much time with somebody I spend as much
time with him as I spend with my wife
I'm with my wife during the during the
during the evening and we're asleep for
a most yeah if you don't count sleeping
time right and so you're gonna have to
apply the same kind of things you're not
gonna stay married for 20 years unless
you have a pact yeah and this you're not
gonna work together forever it's not
it's not that you guys that we sense
that you guys are like there's problems
it's just it's a given we are curious
about how you handle those things and so
when we started asking about it you're
like I don't know why I know you guys
excited we smell blood in the water
sometimes and we want to get us
something juicy I mean that's this is an
air biscuit yeah we came here fair I
[Laughter]
will be like hey checking if you're mad
I had to shoot me well good yeah yeah
all right there's a commitment and that
is healthy and that will move on
draining our you need to take a nap so
what are there any plans can you give us
the scoop on anything like creative will
we expect more the same as there's
something else they were actually just
talking about that on the air
give it to us we're talking about doing
like maybe a series or a movie that's a
big step because like we got so
comfortable and what we do now and like
we're doing good at what we do now so
what you seemed like smosh smosh has got
the movie if does that apply some
pressure well we shall do that now
yeah man yeah you know oh you don't know
about it I don't
maybe you watch this Smosh movie trailer
and it'll apply some pressure for you
guys you know when is that coming up
July 22nd I've been to remember that
because I saw it on the end of the
trailer in that right really yeah like
there's like Shane Dawson had one and
then like camp Takota yeah Caspar Lee
and ksi well I mean I say Smosh because
in terms of tone it's I mean it's not
you guys aren't the same tone or the
same audience I guess but there's some
overlap and just kind of like the craze
it's over the top yeah
like the tone you know so but what we
were talking about is the movie is not
like Arnett or what we usually do we're
thinking of doing like something more
serious so more like a romantic cop yeah
like a romantic comedy but usually it's
just straight comedy like over-the-top
slapstick kind of stuff so it's kind of
scary cuz like we've never done anything
like this so we don't know how they're
gonna feel that me neither
yeah only way to find out is to try it
yeah you might want to try a smaller
form before the movie yeah you know like
a well produced high quality series
first just to see how we do it and then
actually somebody was talking about
directing Hey I don't know how to's but
okay you've got to start doing it cool
well fellas thanks for diving in the
deep end with us now sign this table of
dim lighting here's the marker thanks
fellas
[Music]
and there you have it our biscuit with
Alex and Roy yeah I had a good time
where that one went you know kind of
yeah counselor mode yeah but I but I
think it's coming from a place of well
first of all let them know yeah I want
to I want people to let them know how
they appreciate them being open because
when people come into an air biscuit
situation I think they do know they're
gonna talk about some intimate things
potentially yeah they told us that Olga
Kay told them that she cried write the
inside and they didn't cry didn't or a
little I think they were they had their
guard up or I don't know how they would
put it but well I think it can't record
but if you could just thank them for
that you can do that via their Twitter
that's at Alex wasabi and at Roy wasabi
of course Roy is our oh I and wasabi is
two S's lwas sa bi hashtag ear biscuits
let them know what you thought and also
we also appreciate you leaving a review
on itunes that helps a lot you can
comment along with the conversation on
soundcloud but I hope this came through
in terms of their experience that it's
not like we were trying to get something
out of them to create a great year
biscuit I think by that point in the
conversation there was so much residence
in resonance and kind of knowing two
guys friends business partners we I mean
we're there and we've been there been
there a lot longer than they have so we
just kind of know it's communication is
key I mean to get through this you got
to get through these relational things
in order to not over complicate how to
run a business communication or vice
versa communication is key and conflict
is guaranteed that's what I was saying I
think well one of the interesting things
we haven't really talked about this
before anywhere I don't think but well
maybe a little bit one of the things
that we have seen repeatedly in the
comments on good mythical morning is
people like to point out well there
seems like there's some tension between
you guys I I think behind the scenes
rhettandlink really
hate each other or sometimes there might
be a moment when we're being really
authentic and good mythical more where
one of us kind of pisses the other off
or something like that yeah I think the
thing that I have observed in the
younger generation of like teenagers who
watch our show and are the most vocal
commenters is that I think that they
expect that their friendships shouldn't
be conflict free so if we have conflict
with somebody therefore you can't be a
friend with them and first of all most
of that tension that people are
perceiving is is their perception it's
not really there but when it is there
when we legitimately are getting on each
other's nerves or we legitimately have a
disagreement that kind of makes its way
out into you know our entertainment
that's expected if you if you if you
have any valuable friendship with
somebody you're gonna have that I think
it's it's almost like there's a reaction
from the commenting segment of the GMM
fanbase that they they fear that like
we're gonna break up or something you
know like like their parents are gonna
get a divorce like oh the parents are
fighting rhett and Link are fighting
that means my show is gonna go away no
it's you're gonna you're gonna have
conflict I mean even with with my kids
sure there's certain times where Chrissy
and I get we have conflict because we're
humans and we're in a relationship and
and a lot of times that's in front of
the kids we're having now we're not
having like a like a yelling match in
front of the kids but we're having an
disagreement and and it's how you
handled that conflict and reconcile that
means a lot more to those kids and never
having the conflict in front of them to
begin with right and so like I come out
and say to the kids sometimes like I can
see concern on their faces when we're
disagreeing and so I'll say to them I'll
explain to them this is part of it
this is part of a relationship is that
there's going to be conflict and you
just it's the alarm shouldn't go off
it's how you handle it it's where you
have to hit paydirt and when I hear that
there's somebody who is a
but you know it applies in relationships
you know romantic relationships but also
friendships when I hear that there's a
couple that's getting married and
they're like we never fight I'm like
okay well you are going to and it's
gonna be bad
yeah but I think that with friendships
or you're lying to me
it when I meet somebody who's been who
friendships you like Smosh was an
example of this and I think that wasabi
brothers kind of mirrored this a little
bit it's like the same thing happened
like we mentioned on on the air biscuit
that Smosh didn't seem like they had
talked a whole lot about their feelings
you know
before and I you know but I think that
me and you didn't do a lot of that until
our thirties no you're I know I mean
we've been over 30 for quite some time
now most of my really yours has happened
since yeah I I think it's a product of
being married I think you know being
committed to making a marriage work
you're it's all about the relationship
and it's not complicated by like well
it's just a friendship and you're gonna
you know blow over like two guys who are
just best friends and college roommates
like yeah you take each other off and it
just blows over but I quickly learned in
a marriage that when you're when you're
that close to each other
you you gotta resolve this once it's
when something's at stake and you're
building something together you know a
friendship where there's nothing at
stake and it's just an acquaintance or
it's like oh I just enjoy hanging out
with this person okay I could see how
there might not be conflict but when you
start building something together with
us I'm married to whether that's a
business there's things at stake
children bulls there's people's desires
in that show you know you have to start
taking other people's will into account
there's going to be conflict yeah so I I
think we started to apply what we were
learning in our marriages to each other
because we work we started coming up
against that level of conflict and it's
still not the type of it's it's not not
awkward to have that conversation no you
know whenever we have to have those
conflict resolution moments I most of
the time it's still something
we stumble into like we'll be having a
creative conversation or a creative
disagreement and we've learned to pick
up on it we'll get personal when there's
something under the surface that is the
real problem and it gets personal
right and so what will happen is we'll
be having a creative disagreement but
one of us or both of us is or
disproportionately angry about it and
then of it and then one of us will like
break the seal on like personal honesty
like all right now I'm gonna make this
personal you hurt my feelings when you
said that because I felt like you it was
condescending or you think I'm an idiot
or something right now it and I'll say
something like that and then we'll end
up having an hour and a half
conversation sometimes in front of a
team member that like makes him feel
really awkward yeah we don't do that
anymore that has that we did that back
in North Carolina when we had well we
did that when we were Eric working for
as well and we did that when we were in
the one in the garage with Jason because
there's no place to go yeah I know I
remember good morning Chia Lincoln we
were having and doing that show where it
was unedited that was something that
really brought it to the surface and we
started having these knock-down drag-out
fights and like he would be sitting
there like just waiting to get the
footage so you get it yeah and I did
again I think that yeah I can even
almost feel it in the in the perspective
of some of our younger listeners that
they're like I don't I don't get it I
don't underst
but I think it's just because you
probably have it built something with
someone else to the degree that a
marriage or a business something that
requires so you know it's coming and I'm
just letting you know it's expected you
know communication is key and conflict
is guaranteed maybe I should go the
other way conflict is guaranteed and
communication is key put that on a
t-shirt or a bumper sticker or both and
I know we've talked for a long time
about this and the music playing because
we're coming in for landing and when
this thing is wrapping up but
I don't know how helpful this is to hear
our perspective but hey if it is helpful
then you're rewarded for sticking around
to the end of this ear biscuit because
I'd get a feeling not everybody does
that they might fail a little bit early
not sure if you bailed
well we atlas we just saved your
friendship in your your partnership or
your marriage or whatever you've got we
we just saved it we take full credit for
that you're welcome
but you did hurt my feelings recently
and I'm talking to you listener not Juba
hmm okay that's gonna be awkward
[Music]
[Music]